una decisión aclamada por grupos de
derechos humanos un tribunal de
apelación de parís confirmó que la farsa
debería recibir cargos de complicidad en
crímenes contra la humanidad la primera
empresa francesa en encarar tales cargos
a inicios de 2012 al conflicto sirio se
intensificó en el norte del país y
muchas empresas francesas decidieron
cerrar pero no las farc que quiso
mantener su cementera funcionando
consciente del peligro la compañía
francesa estableció contacto con varios
grupos armados que operaban en la zona
incluido el autodenominado estado
islámico los jueces acusan a la farce de
desviar al menos 13 millones de euros a
yihadistas a cambio de libertad de
movimiento para su personal y
equipamiento descubierto por un grupo de
periodistas en verano de 2016 la
investigación provocó un gran escándalo
ese mismo año el ministro de economía
francés abrió una investigación
preliminar contra la compañía en abril
de 2017 el escándalo forzó la dimisión
del director eric olson dos veces más
tarde el fiscal público de parís comenzó
una investigación por supuesta
financiación del terrorismo ocho
ejecutivos fueron investigados un año
más tarde la farc fue imputada por
múltiples cargos que incluyen
complicidad con crímenes contra la
humanidad financiación de terrorismo
está en peligro de vidas de terceros y
violación de un embargo comercial la
compañía apeló y ganó en parte a finales
de 2019 el tribunal de apelaciones de
parís abandonó al cargo de crímenes
contra la humanidad pero mantuvo los
demás la nulidad fue apelada a su vez
por dos ongs la farsa admitió que pagó
intermediarios para negociar con grupos
armados pero asegura que desconocía las
conexiones de estos grupos con el
terrorismo en 2021 la corte suprema de
francia invalidó la decisión de cancelar
los cargos de complicidad en crímenes
contra la humanidad hoy ha resurgido el
debate un tribunal de apelaciones de
parís confirmó que la farce debe
enfrentar los cargos más graves el
gigante del cemento que cambió su nombre
a holcim tras su fusión en 2015 con el
grupo suizo discute las acusaciones y se
prepara para apelar el caso una vez más